[Música]
ah
en francia hay miles de castillos
abandonados desde hace tiempo tal como
el de cars and wild y tantos apasionados
listos a sacrificar todo para
regresarles la vida a estas
edificaciones pero volverse propietario
es ante todo asumir pruebas milonga
compró su castillo en 2012 y unos
cuantos años más tarde recibió un
baldado de agua fría
sabíamos que necesitaba obras pero de
esas que se hacen en la familia me dan
una mano y se logré en julio 2016 un
pedazo de cielo raso del vestíbulo de
entrada cayó sobre un metro cuadrado más
o menos él descubrimos entonces un
hombre que estaba justo encima llamamos
a un experto en julio 2017 su veredicto
fue que era merula en más de 1.000
metros cuadrados
el oficioso de este ojo es que puede
echar varias raíces exacto de lo que se
conoce como miserias de misterio la
primera tapa son sus pequeños cabellos
finos como de la araña que avanzan para
encontrar agua pueden recorrer hasta
siete células y pedir que hace metro
el hongo genera podredumbre en la madera
visible en esta ventana
la obra gruesa también ha sido afectada
un cuarto de las estructuras
las maderas del siglo 18 han sido
desmontadas en 700 metros cuadrados para
descubrir la piedra y permitir un
tratamiento en profundidad aquí hay que
quemar los muros para suprimir las
raíces que galopan sobre las piedras y
luego la empresa riega un producto
fungicidas muy agresivo es un
antibacterial acepta el muro se
necesitan empresas especializadas por
consiguiente los costos yes
el monto de la factura estará en un
millón de euros el joven propietario ya
cuenta con la mitad de la suma el resto
es incierto por ahora este camino
tortuoso es la regla para numerosos
propietarios de castillos en francia
en voto no fue un propietario sino más
de 25.000 personas las que compraron el
castillo motian de nieve
una proeza posible gracias a una campaña
de financiación participativa
julián martín y román de león fueron
generadores del proyecto nunca
imaginaron que dicha operación sería un
éxito
reinventamos el concepto del patrimonio
mundial hoy en día el castillo le
pertenece al mundo entero a 115 naciones
cuando vimos el grito cuba cuando vimos
burkina faso decidimos esto es más que
patrimonio es más que el proyecto en sí
motivamos a toda una comunidad en
nuestro sueño un poco loco nuestra
apuesta
en 1932 el castillo fue devastado por un
incendio desde entonces la naturaleza
recuperó su lugar
el proyecto consiste en proteger la
ruina para conservar esta armonía que
constituye la poesía del lugar
en el siglo 19 en el arquitecto pero
sobre todo el propietario se inspira a
manos llenas de castillos del lugar con
castillos medievales
inspira destinos y elementos y aquí por
ejemplo tenemos una copia de las
escaleras del edificio del lugar
ah
en pleno corazón de auvernia la
fortaleza de san vidal fue restaurada en
2016 su propietario concretó un sueño de
infancia
pero sedujo particularmente de este
lugar ya que es un viejo castillo
fortaleza que se asemeja a un castillo
playmobil es cierto que es un poco el
villano para todos los niños realizando
tres años sobre el castillo cuando se
les pida que dibujen un castillo estos
cuatro torres con mi patio del centro
como vieron esas viejas piedras me dije
quiero contar la historia de esa
fortaleza entonces
tras la restauración solo falta hacer
vivir el sitio abrirlo al público para
financiar su mantenimiento
desde 2018 cada fin de semana los
habitantes de los pueblos de los
alrededores y comediantes voluntarios
sumergen de nuevo el castillo en el
siglo 16
durante mucho tiempo estuvo abandonada
pero ahora está trabajo ahora es
devolverle su alma a participar y si
todo el mundo no cuenta con los mismos
recursos para pagarse su propio castillo
numerosos sitios como san vidal le
permiten hoy en día a todo el mundo
implicarse en la conservación de este
patrimonio inestimable
[Aplausos]
[Música]